de la recherche et développement
automobile à la production de matériel
médical
le technocentre renault de guyancourt
s'est adapté à la crise sanitaire du coc
vie de 10,9
plus d'une centaine de collaborateurs de
ce site sont mobilisés sur plusieurs
projets notamment la production de
visière destiné au personnel soignant
on a l'ensemble de nos les leçons de
production par impression 3d qui sont
mobilisés pour produire des supports de
ville hier à destination des soignants
on décompte plus tôt ces masques là pour
les filières là pour le personnel
soignant que c'est vraiment des matières
qui sont compatibles avec les protocoles
des inscriptions en hôpitaux 700 visière
ont déjà été produites sur les sites de
guyancourt flins et maubeuge depuis le
début de la semaine un moule a été
conceptualisée pour produire en grandes
séries objectif 4000 visière minimum par
semaine
c'est un moule qui permet de sortir une
pièce plastique avec une cadence très
élevée
donc on injecte en fait un plastique
dans un moule en métal
il y aura pouvoir sortir à la suite très
rapidement donc à permettre parce que
quand vous imprimez en 3d sur une
machine vous allez pouvoir par exemple
sur 24 heures sur les sur des matières
qui sont biocompatible sortir 60 unités
on va pouvoir avoir une capacité une
vitesse de production bien supérieure et
en même temps le linéaire et nos
imprimantes 3d pour la faire d'occasion
qui est la destination des respirateurs
c'est l'autre activité du technocentre
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire la
participation à la conception de
respirateurs à travers deux projets avec
un consortium industriel autour de
michelin du seuil de stmicroelectronics
et d'une initiative d'ingénieur à paris
sur ses deux pôles et là on apporte des
compétences en conception des
compétences achats des compétences
logistique supply chain réalisation
prototype également la partie
industrielle
le projet qui depuis avance et
aujourd'hui
on envisage une mise en production
vraiment de temps avec une production de
5 100 respirateurs rejoint donc une
partie serait là réalisé pour l'instant
ces études que nous avons en cours pour
déconcentre cette situation est inédite
une véritable organisation industrielle
collaborative pour participer à la lutte
contre le coronavirus